[Music]
super exciting day this is ray cameron
just got the keys for this first
adventure so yeah
really looking forward to
this ex-council building built in the
1980s the construction is a traditional
kind of
block and breeze construction which
means that we can do a lot of things
with the property without having to
build lots of stealing we can take away
the internal walls
we can build above possibly three print
houses there's an outside area we can
develop as well on the roof at the
moment we have permission for a 15 bed
hmo as existing planning and also a
large retail unit we're going to walk
through and start showing you about
[Music]
so we've come into the entrance area
here this property is really good for
staging the build because it just
naturally splits into sort of three
elements so cameron's gonna go and get
you through the first element we're
gonna go over towards the right hand
side which is the
retail unit large retail unit it's
basically
as we walk in here you can see the four
windows in front of us they are going to
be
taken away and there'll be a shop front
basically going into this area we're
just going to come over here towards the
the retail unit this will be the back
part of basically this whole pit we
knocked right through the the floor will
be raised over here this is a large
space roughly about
295 square meters but the good thing is
it has such a high ceiling
that we could actually possibly float
another floor on top of it and add extra
apartments we don't have any electricity
in the building so it's really hard to
see at the moment and what this big
space is like we will try to capture
some pictures later
okay so we've seen the retail element of
the development
and we're now going to go to the left
and again
excellent thing about these properties
is that all the internal walls can be
stripped out so this can whole area can
be reconfigured so kevin's going to talk
about functionality okay we're going to
step over here and this is the area
where it's going to be a five bed hmo a
room will have a quadrant style
uh shower
as you can see these walls will be all
removed and it will be replanned this
will be
likes of our kind of
kitchen area with a kind of communal
area
and it goes right the way around here
i'm just going to walk through here and
show you what
we've been talking about this
block
and beam setup which when you look up at
the ceiling here you'll see this large
beam and then there's big squares of
concrete which is we call the block
and if you look at the wall this breeze
block none of this is supporting in the
whole building which is so great this
can all be removed
[Music]
okay so these are the approved plans and
they're fine for the purposes done we
have the planning permission that's
great
but
we've actually had an academy member
dave taylor from blackpool he's from dm
property group he's advised us that we
can possibly reconfigurate these plans
we're just going to go on to the area
over here again in the ground floor
where these hmos will extend into it's
quite dark so if you can just bear with
us we'll try our best to give you an
idea of what's here and the the vast
amount of space
[Music]
it's just the bathrooms would have been
here initially
[Music]
okay so we're back in the reception area
now gonna head upstairs currently got
planning for 10 bed hmo but again
hopefully with dave taylor that will
change
so we're just going to go upstairs now
we're here on the first floor now
of the 10 bed hmo and this will give you
an idea of the kind of light natural
light we'll have from the windows for
each room
and now we'll follow outside to the
other section of the 10-bed hmo give you
an idea of the space and what we're
hoping to do here
[Music]
these internal walls can all go yep
let's give you an idea of the rooms in
here
again these
walls will be removed
this will be the upstairs kitchen giving
you an idea of the kind of common
kitchen
and
as we walk back out on the right hand
side and we'll be like a living area
we've decided to separate the two areas
which i think will be better for having
an open pan
kitchen especially the amount of people
that we're going to have here
and it's nice to have that separate area
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see this is a zen to the
second part of the 10 bed hm on the
first floor lots of
windows here for natural light
again this place will be configurated
into the individual rooms
[Music]
if you can see the kind of gray areas
this is the kind of front of the
building that wraps around to the side
the proposal is that we'll hopefully
possibly put up three houses here and it
will go into this area at the back as we
look over here
outside the area as well which could be
some decking that will add a bit more
appeal to this 1980s building but the
fantastic thing about here is that we
shouldn't have any restrictions this
type of development for me this is
something that's new because i'm more
into the kind of building over here
which is a grade two listed building
which i've done in the past but as far
as this building goes it's fantastic to
work with if you look over the back here
over my shoulder you'll see like the
wall market which
they've recently just finished
renovating there's been a lot of
investment in the area which is
fantastic for me and for the
developments that i'm looking at in this
area also they're regenerating the
the train station um the art galleries
the museums and just a massive amount of
money being plowed into this area and
they are in april hopefully reapplying
to be a city
[Music]
the penthouses will be set back slightly
with balconies which i think will look
amazing and also it looks more
aesthetically pleasing from a planning
point of view
we're just going to tidy up the outside
area and have like an area for the
residents we have to obviously provide
right away for this fire exit from this
other building here and but we do have
the rights over this area we put a
couple of parking spaces and also just
an outside area for the potential
tenants that are going to stay here just
to chill out
end of the guided tour this is
first of the sort of video diary i hope
it's giving you a good idea of the scale
of the project
just really where we're at with it sort
of bringing dave taylor in
maximize what can be done here still a
bit of an unknown definitely i think um
we can definitely make a big improvement
to the existing plans and the layout and
with additional penthouses and
additional
rooms that we're going to create yeah
really really really looking good
obviously there's going to be stumbling
blocks we're going to have hiccups and
hopefully people are going to do this
journey if you're thinking about doing a
commercial development yourself that you
can pick up some good ideas yeah
and yeah we'd be quite happy to
hopefully document as much as we can
yeah moving forward and hopefully not
bore you with too much
and be more upbeat yeah bye cool